So, what's really great about Pig is that it abstracts
away from the user the actual implementation of how the
calculation is done. So, you can write in a more
abstract language what kinds of operations should be performed to
your data. You can say, for example, join this data
set to this data set, or filter out this data
set, or reduce this data. But you're not telling it
how to do the analysis. And then Pig can decide
the fastest way to do it for you. So instead of having to write
very detailed jobs describing exactly what should
be done, you can just specify in an
abstract sense the calculation that needs to be done, and you can let the
computer do the hard work of figuring out the faster way to do the calculation.